I've told you before that Secretary of
Transportation Pete butterjudge is
really really good when he appears on
right-wing media and when he's
responding to his right-wing critics
will Pete Buda judge decimated the
homophobic comment of Marjorie Taylor
Green from over the weekend let's start
with her comment now I you could check
out my live stream from over the weekend
from the Trump rally I saw Marjorie
Taylor green talks about Pete Buddha
judge without even seeing the clip I
assumed and I know that sometimes when
you assume you end up made a fool out of
but I assumed that if Marjorie is
talking about Pete it's probably
homophobic it just just the odds are if
you've got if I had to bet I would say
if Marjorie Taylor green is talking
about Pete Buddha judge there's probably
some homophobic element to what she says
and indeed there was indeed there was
here is what Marjorie said about the
Secretary of Transportation more
American than the Roar of a V8 engine
under the hood of a Ford Mustang or
Chevy Camaro an incredible
feel of all that horsepower
but Democrats like Pete butterjudge want
to emasculate the way we drive right
right of course the gay Secretary of
Transportation wants to emasculate the
way people drive now what does that mean
emasculate the way people drive
I don't know but it probably has
something to do with electric vehicles
right
and force all of you to rely on electric
vehicles after they shut down your great
Michigan Auto industry by the way many
michigan-based automakers are making
electric vehicles making that comment
particularly stupid
um let's go now to Pete bootage's
response he appeared on Fox news with
Neil Cavuto he was asked about these
comments and his answer is pretty funny
you've been pushing for this you've been
very consistent with that but
representative Marjorie Taylor green uh
the Georgia Republican at a rally in
Michigan said this past weekend uh the
Mr budditez is trying to emasculate the
way we drive by as she goes on to
explain by supporting environmentally
friendly Transportation but what did you
think of her wording he's trying to make
everybody feminine by making us drive
really cool fast cars that you don't
need to gas up and can charge in your
driveway it's really really really
feminine of him
I I literally don't even understand what
that means I mean my sense of manhood is
not connected to whether my vehicle is
fueled by gasoline or whether it's
fueled by electricity well maybe it
should be Pete this is a practical map
are you offended were you offended by
that too because even people who you
know share her politics didn't share
that view
it was a strange thing to say uh you
know to be honest there are other
members of Congress that I pay more
attention to when I'm thinking about
opinions that that really matter or
ideas that are going to be critical to
engage with I do think we need to zoom
out a little bit and I know people want
to make this ideological they want to
make it political we're talking about
something like electric vehicles we're
talking again about a very practical
matter which is Imagine taking the issue
of getting off of fossil fuels at least
at the tailpipe for the way we drive
around and thinking that the issue
really is about how the Secretary of
Transportation wants to emasculate
others
and implicit in that of course of course
is the fact that uh Pete Buddha judge is
is a gay man it's just unbelievable and
I know I've told the story before but
I'll remind you of it I've experienced
this there's something about the
electric cars that really triggers a lot
of these right Wingers and I've
described before
more than a couple dozen instances where
when I go anywhere and I park in the
parking lot you know a grocery store or
not a Starbucks of course not but you
know we're at places I really do go I
will often Park like in the furthest
spot from the front door and I've always
actually done this just because I just
walk more right I'll get an extra walk I
walk more to the front door and then I
walk more back to my car but also I am
kind of protective of my electric
vehicle and I don't want to park near
people and I like to keep it far away
and a couple dozen times I will come out
and there's one of these big just gas
guzzling Behemoth pickup trucks with a
thin blue line sticker and once it was
with a Confederate flag parked right
next to my car they're intimidating me
they're really intimidating me and also
just on the road the pickup truck people
uh with the with the stickers the Trump
stickers whatever
at the at a green light when a red light
goes green just zooming off and leaving
leaving me in a cloud of black smoke
probably cost them costing them a dollar
in gas to for for that show of manhood
there's something wrong with these
people there really is and Marjorie
Taylor green talking about a V8 Camaro
and Mustang uh and electric vehicles
being emasculating is basically the
exact same thing will they ever come
around yeah I think eventually they will
because electric cars are clearly the
way things are going so I think
eventually they will come around and
some right-wingers have that uh that
that F-150 Lightning pickup truck
Electric
is selling pretty damn well I have to
say the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of Chilly sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night